President Trump is promising to tackle
school safety he used an address to the
nation yesterday to talk about the
shooting today the president will travel
to his Mara Lago Resort in Florida and
that is located about 30 miles north of
parkland but the White House has not
given details of his plans to visit
victims and families major Garrett is at
the White House major good morning good
morning a pattern is emerging with
President Trump and high profile crimes
when committed by immigrants legal or
otherwise there are rapid calls for new
and restrictive policies after mass
shootings the White House tendency is to
say wait gather facts and there have
been no calls for restrictions on access
to firearms and the president's emphasis
on mental health its undercut by his own
record let us pray for healing and for
peace in the wake of Wednesday's high
school massacre president Trump consoled
a nation in grief calling for prayers
for the Fallen no mention of the
semi-automatic rifle at the heart of the
carnage for the president mental illness
was the culprit we are committed to
working with state and local leaders to
help secure our schools and tackle the
difficult issue of mental health mr.
Trump consistently invokes mental health
not gun control after mass shootings
when 26 were shot dead in a rural Texas
Church last November this is how the
president viewed it this isn't a guns
situation that this is a mental health
problem in February of last year mr.
Trump signed a bill killing an Obama era
regulation which allowed the Social
Security Administration to provide
information on severely mentally
disabled people to the national
background check database there are a
number of different ways that we look to
protect our citizens
last December on the fifth anniversary
of the Sandy Hook school shooting that
killed 26 people including 20 children
White House press secretary Sarah
Sanders was asked to describe
administration efforts to prevent mass
casualties shootings I know that they're
looking at some of the mental health
issues that something the president has
raised before but in terms of a specific
policy that we're moving forward with
that would have prevented that I'm not
aware of what that would be
along with repealing that one Obama
a regulation the White House is also
endorsed reducing long-term allocations
to Medicaid Medicaid is one of the
largest providers of mental health
services across the country John Major
thank you